で 隣は音楽の教室やってるので
皆様はこちらよりは向こうに興味が出たら困るということで
マイクロフォンをつけるようにと言われてありますけど
この衣とマイクロフォンっていうのはなかなか合わない
じゃあうるさくなったらその時使いましょう
では よろしくお願いします
えっと まあ今日のテーマはまあ少々難しいというか
まあ私は少々というと
まあ結構大変骨が折れることになると思いますけど
それからこの内容はものすごいたくさんあります
だからどうしようかと
一応スライド作ったんですけど
あの あまりにも専門用語が出るんだから
仏教用語出るんですから
この途中でやめちゃったんです
まあそういうことで それなりに簡単に考えて理解できるポイントと言ったって
このただ何なのかっていうぐらいは理解してほしいんです
で あの英訳で言えばこのProblem of self deceptionという名前になりますけど
皆様方 セルフディフェンスという言葉はよく知ってますね
自衛隊の自衛 で 私はself deceptionという自分を騙すというね
自分で自分を騙すっていう
そこでこのMatrix of the mindで
心っていうのはものあまりにも複雑に絡み合って
どうにもわからないように機能するんです
はい で あの 自分が自分を騙すとは本当でしょうかと
まずそんなのは本当に私たちは自分を騙してるんでしょうかということ
はい まずはdefinitionというか定義から始まります
もう一つは余計な余分なことを言い忘れたんですけど
この これは心理学的な説明なんですけど
あの 西洋心理学では全くもない概念なんです
で 仏教 仏教の世界ででもほとんど扱わないポイントなんです
で 本もないんです で ものすごく難しい
誰も読まないところで
もう専門家の専門家以外読まない
ほんのわずかなところで説明してあるだけで
でも知ってる人はそれで全部物の見事に理解はできますけど
まあそういうことだからなかなか難しい
ですから 全く新しい概念として聞いてみればよろしいと思います
騙されているのは自分自身です
ので 自分が気づいていないこと
これ定義の中に入る 定義書こうと思ったんですけど
定義は書けないんです
で 自分自身騙されているんだから自分が気づかないんです
どうせ騙されている人は気づくはずもないんですよ
だから気づいてない 気づかないっていうことははっきり覚えておいてください
気づきません 例えば これから私は説明しますけど
皆様方 本当に腹が立って怒るかもしれません
そんなのはありえないんだと
だから これはあまり我々説法でも言わない項目なんです
言って怒りを買うことになるんです
みんなの信仰 仏教に対する愛着を深めるではなくて
えらい敵を作ることになるんです
それぐらい気づかないんで騙されているんだから
2番目のポイントは他人の関係がないこと
決して他人に騙されてるわけじゃないんです
これは自分がなんです
自分が自分を騙すんですね
だから他人との全く関係ない
これがすごいややこしいんです
で  3番目には わかりやすく言えば
自分が決して認めない自分の隠れている性格です
自分が決して認めない
いかなる場合でも認めない自分の隠れている性格なんです
だから自分で自分のことを知ってるんだから
とんでもない そんなことは絶対ないんだよと
無念派って言うんです
だからこの講義はどうしても喧嘩になると思います
で 決して認めないということも
これ定義なんです はい
それでその 3項目を覚えたところで
ちょっと除外者がいるんです
で たくさんいるんですけど
なかなか日本語の単語が頭に浮かばないんだから
まあ適当にいくつかだけ書きました
まあ一応これ 1番目というわけじゃないんです
まあただ頭に浮かんだ順番で
で 偽善者ですね この人は自分で決めて偽善行為になり
行為に偽善者になっているのです
表でやっていることと裏でやっていることは区別しているのです
自分を騙しているのではなく
相手を騙して利益を得ているのです
詐欺師なども同じなのです
それははっきりしていますよ
偽善者っていうのは 偽善者が世間に向かってはすごい善人
私は悪いことをしませんよと言うんですよ
でも裏で隠れていろんな悪いことはする
だから世間が偽善者と言うんだけど
それを本人は我々よりもよく承知なんです
だからそちらには騙されている機能はないんです
例えば政治家が国のため命かけてと言ったら
もうその政治家は知ってます
俺がどれぐらい儲かるかということにしか興味がないんだぞと
心の中でそれは知っている
口では命かけるんです
国民のために それも偽善者なんですけど
決してこちらには入れません
本人は騙されているわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと計画を立てて
そういうことをやっているんだから
意識があるんです だから除外するんです
詐欺師いるでしょ あらゆる巧妙ないろんな方法で人を騙すとかね
それをその人は知っています
言っていることは全部嘘だと
ごまかしだと だからそういう人々は除外する
それで多重人格者がいるんですね
この人は病気ですから
まあしょうがないんですよ
ところで我々 私は仏教の者だから
この精神的な病気という場合は
この ひどい状態で 西洋の定義と同じく
普通の人よりはちょっと取り扱いにくいということで
別にそういう人々をガイドしなくちゃいけないんですね
仏教でもできないわけないんだけど
我々はそういう診療的なことはやらないし
お釈迦様も禁止しているんです
ある日さえ ある人が何か精神的な何か問題ある人が
何か何か治療する方法ないかと聞いたんですけど
ものすごい病気な人のことは全く素人が何か方法がないかと聞くのはそれ自体危険でしょうし
このものの重さっていうのをわかってない
人の命の大事さっていうのはね
例えば私に直々この精神的な患者さんが来て
なんとか助けてくださいと言っても
私はかなり手を引くんですよ
できないわけじゃないんです
しかし 手を引くんです
なぜかというと その人って病気ですから
この社会の目で見たら病気ですから
それなりの免許を持っていて
資格を取っている もう俗世間でもね
プロが扱わなくちゃいけないんですね
体に感染感染することはできないかもしれませんだけど
例えば薬与えなくちゃいけないとかね
いろいろある場合は それはもうその専門家がしなくちゃいけないことでやってはいけない
もし心理 神経科というんですか
この psychiatrist という医者たちが
ぎっしりとヴィパッサナーのブッダのやり方を勉強するならば
彼らには素晴らしい診療所を作れます
で 特にこの病気な人の場合は
時間付きっきりで面倒見なくちゃいけないんです
で それはただの職業になるんだから
それだったらお金を取らなくちゃいけないし
それはだから仏教には
特に出家者には禁止なんです
決してやってはいけないことです
一つは人の仕事を奪うことになるし
でも修行の世界でなくなっちゃうんです
ずっと患者さんに付きっきりで
で 普通の病気だったら早く治るんですけど
精神的な病気っていうのはもう何年かわからない
まあだからこの まあ病気ですから
それはまあ別なプロが扱うもので
物事の流れが頭の中で断片化しているんですね
この多重人格っていうのはね
あの ただそれだけのことで
別に皆様方時々思ってますね
なんか別な人格が入り込むんだと
幽霊みたいに そんなのはないんです
ただ 同じ人の人格が断片化しているだけ
で 様々な人格を演じる時は完全にその人
その人格に成りきっているのです
結果として自分を騙しているが
そのカテゴリには入りにくいんです
で 例えば人格者がこの子供の別な名前を演じたりするし
別な名前を演じたとしても
結局本人なんですよ でもそれつなげてくれないんですね
その時は本人決してそういうことで
本人本当に自分を騙しているんです
大体多重人格者っていうのはいろいろ問題があって
よく一般的に言うのは
この性的虐待を受けた場合はね
まあよく起こるんだそうとかね
本当かどうかわかりませんですけど
なくても虐待というものは一般的に受けると
もう大体人格者に多重人格者になる可能性はないわけじゃないんです
で 体が逃げるんですね
状況から うまくこの別な人格で成りきって逃げるんです
あるいは自分を責める時もありますから
その場合でも それぞれ人格に変わって自分を責めたりする
これ明らかに騙し機能なんですけど
こちらで扱っている問題ではありません
これが病気っていうことで
はい で また除外者の多重人格者の続きなんですけど
普通な人間も結局は多重人格者なのです
これは私も前の講義でも言いました
初めの講義でも我々誰でも多重人格者であって
決して本音では生きていられるものではありません
その時その時 我々は何かを仮面を被って演じるんです
だから結局は私たちも多重人格者なんです
しかし 彼らは複数の人格をそれなりに管理しているのです
というのは我々のこと
我々は自分持っている複数の人格を
まあそれなりに管理しています
一つの人格を演じる時も
裏に別な人格も潜んでいることを知っているのです
私たち知っているんですよ
裏で別な人格もあるんだと
私たちの場合はね 私たちの場合はある人に対してある人格を演じる
しかし 心の中知ってます
別なところで自分が別な人格だと
瞬時に入れ替えることもできます
例えば 弱い人をいじめている時は
ものすごい体力ある力強い人がドーンと来て打ちちゃうと
瞬時に自分がもういじめ役をやめちゃって惨めな役をやったりするでしょうね
だからまあ瞬時に入れ替えることもできます
それを忘れた瞬間に問題が起こすのです
時々忘れるんですよ それでその瞬間では問題なんです
しかし 複数の人格を一本につなげつないでいる
病人にはそれができない
で 私たちの場合は まああれもこれもこれもこれも私だよと一本につなげているんです
あの人格も あの時は人を殴ったのは私です
あの時は人を助けたのは私ですと
そうやって一本につなげているんです
病気には 病気な人にはそれできないんです
もうわからない 別人格になったら
差はそれだけなんです
はい また除外者がいます
で 誤解者というか 勘違い者というか
ちょっとわからないんですけど
何かを誤解して自分の理解に正直に生きる
で 世の中の事実を知るんじゃなくて
何か変なものを誤解する
で 誤解して 例えばの話で悪い悪人なら殺すのは正しいと思って思っていて殺人を起こす
悪人ならもうどうしようもないでしょう
殺さなくていかんではないかとかね
悪人を放っておいちゃうと世間が悪くなるんだよと
だから世間を救うために
人類のために 我々は悪人を殺すべきやと言って悪人殺しに行く
これがもう勘違いした誤解者なんですね
これはもう世の中ですごいたくさんいるんですね
で ヨーロッパの方ではもう嫌になるほどいるし
イスラムの中東の国々でもいくらでもいるし
そこでこのオウムグループに入った人々も
あれほど勉強していたのに平気で人を殺したりする
人を殺す薬作ったり 道具作ったり
あれって正しいとと思ってやっているんですね
だから誤解されているんですね
罪を犯しているのに善行為をしていると勘違いしているから
自分を騙していることには変わりはありませんが
除外者なんです その場合も除外者なんです
なぜ除外するかというと
これはもうその誤解解いてあげれば
あんた間違ってるんだよと
これはもう犯罪は犯罪だよと
はっきり正しいことを教えれば直っちゃいますね
ですから そういうわけでここで除外します
はい 次に このマインドコントロールされている人々
この人々も良いことだと思って悪いことをしているのです
しかし 自分を騙しているわけではありません
他人に騙されているだけです
マインドコントロールの場合は明らかに他人に騙されている
ですから 自分で自分が騙したというカテゴリーには入らないのです
では マインドコントロールしている人々に責任ないかというと
そうでもないんです 本人は自分で判断しているが
その判断は他人によって制御されているのですから
自分で判断していますけど
結局その判断は管理されているんですね
それからこの除外するのは
この一時的発作 時々発作を起こしちゃうんですね
まああまりいい例はないんですけど
酒やら麻薬やら感情の爆発などの原因で正しいと思ってやることも
実は悪いことであっても
自分で自分を騙すカテゴリーにはカテゴリーではありません
我々感情の発作を起こしちゃうと
よくいろんな悪いことをするんですよ
子供を守るために相手を殺したとかね
殺されるんだから殺したとかね
[背景音楽]あるいは酒麻薬でやられる時でも
何するか悪いことをしちゃうんですよ
しかし その人々は自分を騙しているわけじゃないんです
その時は他の選択はない
ただそれだけ 例えば麻薬中毒になっちゃって
人が見たところでもう獣で見えたとする
獣を見えちゃうと 獣を養うのは当たり前でしょうにということで獣を養う
しかし 常識な人間から見れば
普通人を殴った殴って怪我させたことなんですね
本人は認めない 私はもうそんなことやってないんだと
だから騙されているかというと
そうじゃないんですね
それは感情の発作の麻薬のことですからね
酔いが覚めたら間違いに気づく可能性もあります
酔っ払ってやったことは
酔いが覚めたらね やっぱりそれか後で
あれはまずかったなとと思ったりするでしょうし
だからそれは騙す機能にはありません
大体それまだいますか
いや それで終わりです
除外さんも有罪です 今除外したんだからといって無罪わけじゃないんです
たとえ酒に酔って何もわからなくなっちゃって悪いことをしても悪いんです
その時判断できなかったんだからということは
もう仏教では認めない
悪い行為したんだから
その瞬間で自分の意思でやってるんです
麻薬によって人間が食べ物に見えたと
それで殺したと 言うと
本人が食べ物を食べようと思ったかもしれませんけど
本人がやっぱり人を殺したことには変わりはないんです
その時はちゃんと自分の意思で
その時でも行動している
だから明らかに罪は罪なんです
今除外した人々のみんなの行為は罪なんですが
有罪ですけど もうこちらの今から差別をしているポイントから除外するだけ
それからもう一度 このデフィニションに定義に戻ってみましょう
同じ定義 前も出た同じスライドなんです
騙されているのは自分自身ですので
自分が気づかない 気づいていないこと
他人の関係がないこと
わかりやすく言えば 自分が決して認めない自分の隠れている性格ということなんです
だからあのグループを除外するんです
こういう定義には入らないんです
適合者って誰ですか？と
自分を騙すということには
除外者以外のものは適合する
ミノタウロスみたいな言葉なんです
ですけど あの除外者以外みんな適合するんです
要するに常識的な人間です
知識人で あれこれと物事をよく考える人も
良い人間になろうと努力する人も入っているんです
あの除外者のリストにないでしょ
それであのポイント終わり
では 今日のテーマで扱うのはどんな人間かというと
常識人間 一般的な道徳を守って
社会秩序を守って 普通のインテリ人間で生きている人々のことなんです
それからいろんなことを勉強して
よく理解して それに従って生活している
この常識人というか 普通の人というか
立派な人というか そういう人々の話なんです
今日は そういう人々にケチつけようとしているんです
これから 世間から見れば何のことはない
素晴らしい人だと言われる人々が今日のテーマなんです
それで難しいのはこのポイントなんです
知っていて自分を騙すことはできません
例えば どうやって私が自分で自分を騙してやるぞということができますかね
できるんでしょう 例えば
この水をガラスに水を入れて
じゃあこれがコーヒーだと思ってやるぞと
コーヒーの味にして その熱いもうホットコーヒーにして飲んでやるぞと
自分にはできないんですよ
自分知ってるんだから
水だと 他人にはできますよ
暗示かけちゃって これからあんたに熱いコーヒーコーヒーあげますから
気をつけて飲んでくださいと
美味しいですよと 香り嗅いでみてください
いい香りでしょう？と言ったら
暗示かけられた人々はただの水を感じて
もう熱い熱いと言いながら
やっぱり香りがいいとかね
飲んだりする それで脳のからくりでちゃんとコーヒーの味もする
でもお腹に入るのは水なんですけど
これが自分でするのは難しい
できません 知らないで自分を騙すことも不可能です
それで その状況を何も知らない状態で自分を騙してやろうということもあり得ないんです
えーと 自分の知識 思考
感情の無作為な的な絡み合いによって騙されてしまうのです
これがこの 3番目で答え出しているんです
我々の知識がありますし
思考がありますし それから感情もあります
それはもう無作為にも適当じゃないんですよ
ごちゃごちゃ絡み合うんです
知識と感情が絡み合っちゃうし
あるいは妄想と感情が絡み合っちゃうし
あるいは妄想と勉強したものが絡み合っちゃうし
どちらどっちだっていう絡み合うだからね
わからない これで騙されてしまうんです
決してこの我々誰一人も
あえて 例えば鏡を見て
例えば 60歳ぐらいの人が私って 20歳ぐらい若いですねとかそう思わない
言っても口先で それもできない
まあ案上手な人だったら
60歳のおばあさんも 20歳にしてあげることはできますけど
しかし 本人がその 20歳の気分になるだけで
決して 20歳になるわけじゃないんです
だから この騙しっていうのはものすごい巧妙で
我々の思考 妄想 勉強したもの
それから感情 これはもう適当に現れるわけじゃないんですよ
何が浮かぶかわからないんですね
脳の中で そんなのはあっちこっちあっちこっち浮かんで来て
絡み合ったりして で その状態から我々は騙されるんです
とんでもない結果になるんです
これは騙す機能なんですね
騙す この中身なんですね
はい 騙すとはどういう意味？まあ
だいたいたくさんありますから
淡々と読めばいいと思いますけど
常識的な人間は良い人間になりたいと思っている
しかし 良い人間になる人々は稀なのです
これおかしいでしょう
世の中は誰でも良い人間になろうと思っているのに
なる人っていうのは稀なんです
良い 皆良い人間になりたいのに
なぜ良い人間がこの世で少ないのでしょうか？それ考えてほしいんです
世の中でみんな良い人間になりたいんだけど
世界は悪人一色でしょうね
何でしょうかね これが騙されているんだということなんです
自分が自分を騙しているんだということなんです
はい  [咳]例えば努力しないから
よくわからないからなどの答えは成り立ちません
それでなんで世の中で悪人
善人は少ないですかというと
みんな言うかもしれません
それは良い人になろうと努力していないでしょ
あなたの努力足らんでしょうとか
あるいはあんた誤解しているでしょ
だからあんたいい人間になれんだよと
私はそんな返事は成り立たないと思っているんです
そんなこと言ったって
そのような人々は良い人間になろうとしないのです
別に努力しない人はあえて良い人間になろうと思ってないでしょうね
だからその人は別に除外ですよ
俺は別に良い人間にならなくていいやという人がもう覚悟して一般的に生きているんです
だから努力足らんということは入らないんです
良い人間になりたいと思った人は努力しているんです
そのその他大勢の人々は良い人間になろうとしているのに
次に繋げます そう簡単にはなれない
世の中の多数の人間が良い人間になろうとしていますよ
でも簡単にはならない
自分の性格は変わらない
性格は逆に悪くなるケースも多々あります
良い人間になろうと思って悪人で終わるということは結構あるでしょうに
昔 ローマ教会がね 戦争したり人殺したりもしたでしょうね
それは世間を良い世間にしてあげようと思ってやったことだから
結局は人殺しばっかしやっていたんですけど
何かが変ですよ 何かが
この世の中の人間を見てると何かが変なんです
いい人間になろうとするんだけど
変わらないっていうことは変でしょう
だって何でも変わるはずなのに
何でも変わるはず 我々の体でも食事だけ変えれば体まで変わるでしょうに
住んでる場所を変えれば
例えば外国行ったりどこか行ったり
それだけでも性格いろんなもの変わるでしょうに
たった場所を引っ越しただけでも
なのになんでこのいい人間になろうとしているのに変わらないんですか？性格が変わるんだ
何かが変なんですね これが仏教心理学でワンチャカダンマ
これはもうセルフディセプションというね
まあワンチャカというのは騙すということで
ダンマというのは法ということでね
なかなかいい単語が浮かばなかったんです
ワンチャカダンマというんです
いわゆる自分が自分を騙しているということ
はい どのように騙すのかと
自分自身が良い人間だ
良いことをしているのだ
日々努力しているのだ
日々成長しているのだと思っている
しかし根っこは変わらない
思ってるんだけど そういうふうに騙しているんです
どんな人でも自分がいい人間だと思っているんですよ
これが問題なんです だから正直に頑張ってます
だから正直にあ 自分がそれなりに成長しているんだと思っているんです
しかし 人間の本来の姿
根っこっていうところはそのまま
だから善行為に期待するほどの結果もない
それも明らかな事実でしょうに
我々はいいことをするはするはするは
しかし この仏典なんかに行っているようないい結果が出てこないんですよ
ちょっと政治的な話にしたっても
例えば日本の国はいろんな国々にものすごく援助しているんです
しかし お金がなくなるだけで全然いい結果は出てこない
イラク人解放してあげるぞと
イラク人がそれですっごく望んでいるんだぞと言ってイラクを潰しちゃったんだけど
イラク人にものすごく怒られて殺されているんです
いいことをしたならば
本当にいい結果になるはずでしょうに
だからそういうところでよくわかる
それは別に騙し切りに入りませんだけど
それはまああえて騙している
嘘をついて騙していることだから
それは悪いことだということははっきりしていますけど
私たちそうじゃないでしょうに
我々は自分なりにいろいろいいことをしている
人を助けたりもするし
親切にしてあげたりもするし
毎日頑張っているし でも何か期待するほどの結果が出ないんです
この仏典にあるこの善行為の結果の話を聞くと
みんな本当かと疑うほどなんです
ほんのちょっとの布施をして
ものすごい幸福に恵まれたと
信じられないほど幸福に恵まれたと
というふうな話 エピソードたくさんあるんです
それは仏教の人々も読んではいるんですけど
誰もあんまり真剣に信じてないみたいんです
なぜかというと このエピソード
物語に出てくる人々よりも
布施していますよ 読んでいる人々は
でもいい結果は得られない
これって何なのかと 良い行為に良い結果は決まっている
そんなのは決まってる法則です
良い人間になろうとする努力は実るはず
必ずも実るはず 良い人間になろうとするならば
因果法則の世界っていうのはそんなもんですよ
俗世間で我々は必ず実現できるでしょうに
例えばもうご飯食べたいと思ったら
お金あったら店に行ったら必ずしもご飯食べられるでしょうに
なぜならば因果法則揃ってますから
自分がお腹が空いている
お金も持っている レストランも営業している
で 入って「これちょうだい」と注文したら
必ずしもそれをくれる
これを食べて食べたら
美味しく食べられてお腹が満腹になるという結果があるでしょうに
行為に結果があるんです
ないはずがないんです
結果が良くなければ原因に問題がある
もし結果が良くなければね
原因に問題がある 例えばレストランに行って注文して美味しいものを食べたんですけど
殴られたと 警察に連れて行かれたというと
原因に何か問題があるんでしょうに
だから美味しくご飯を食べたところで
まあ何て言いますか 「
ありがとうございます」と店の人に言われなかったと
その代わりに殴られたか
警察に捕まれたか どちらという悪い結果になったならば
当然自分の原因でしょ
自分がお金払わなかったということで
だから もし我々は良い人間に
世界が良い人間になろうとしているのに
世界にほとんどないということは
何か原因に問題あります
本当に良い人間になろうとしているのかということが疑問なんです
今日はそれがポイントなんです
本当に良い人間になりたいのかと
疑問が生じる しかし 自分ではわかりません
これがちょっと足引っ掛けになるんです
こういうふうに考えると疑問が生じるんでしょうかね
なんで世の中良い人間にならないんでしょうかと
なんで世の中一向に良くならないのかと
いうと原因があるでしょうに
ということは 我々の努力に問題あるんです
我々は一向に良い人間になろうとしてないんです
我々は一向に世の中を良くしようとしてないんです
それを認めないだけ そうしたらすぐ良くなりますよ
世の中っていうのは 瞬時に
良い世界作ろうと思っちゃえば
いとも簡単に良い世界になります
でもならないんです 理由は
我々は本気でそう思ってないんです
で 認める？誰一人も本気でいい人間になろうと思ってないこと
この世界 この国が良い国になってほしいと本気で思ってないということを認めないでしょう
そんなこと言ったら侮辱されたと思うでしょうに
ここが問題なんです 我々は結果論で喋るんです
でも結果はそういう結果でしょうにと
その結果作ったのはあなた方でしょうにと
結果は戦争だったら 戦争したのはあなた方でしょうにと
ということは仏教の反論なんです
でも人間は認めないという気持ちでいるんです
はい どのように騙すかということで
自分の本当の気持ちはわからないこと
これが問題です  一番目
私たちは我々の本当の心
本当の気持ちはわからない
別なことを言うんですよ
一番悪い例っていうのは
この精神的な問題ある人々
この精神的な問題ある人々を聞いてアドバイスを受けるはカウンセリングを受けるは受けるは
いくらアドバイスしてあげても
カウンセリングしてあげても
全くも治らない で それにしたら
我々よりも精神的におかしい人々はものすごく心理学知ってるんです
片っ端から本を読む いろんな本を読む
私は知ってる人々いますよ
ものすごい もうもうもう
大量に本持ってます ものすごい量
本持ってるだけじゃなくて
随分早く読むんです 読んだものを覚えてるんです
それで一体何見えるかという
自分の精神的な問題に何か解決法ないのかと探しているようなんですよ
それだったら まあどんな心理学の本でも
人間は病気にするために書いてないでしょうに
完璧に書いてないかもしれませんだけど
病気にさせてやるぞという人は全くないでしょうに
なんとかアドバイスあるでしょうに
なのに なんで効かないのかと
なんででしょうかね 本人は治してほしくないんです
あれ騙しなんです 見事に
しかし認めない 私は必死ですよと
あるこのうつ病の人に
私はいくらかこういうことをしなさいと
いろいろアドバイスしたんです
私はちゃんと学問的にうつ病って
その人といろいろ話してみて
で いろんな状況を調べなくちゃいかんから
まあどこら辺に問題あったかということは
まあ私は自分では発見して
まあ脳が動けばいいんです
で まあちょっと重症みたいで
まあそれにはちょっとそのそれなりの脳の運動にはちょっと時間はかかります
もし私が治療したならば
毎日来てくださいと言ってそっちっきりで必ず治してみせますけど
それは自分の意地であって
本人の気持ちじゃないんで
で そういうことを言うと
一つ一つに見事な反論を持ってくるんです
そんなことはちょっとこの
まあちょっとやりにくいと
それをやったら恥ずかしいんじゃないかと
そんなこと言ったら まあ家の人々にいろいろ言われますよとか
あらゆることを言うんです
毎日朝早く起きて毎日１時間ぐらい歩いてみてください
そんなできませんと 毎日いろいろ忙しいんだ
どうしようね 私はそれでもうもう諦めたんです
あんた自分の病気本当に楽しんでるでしょうねとか
楽しいでしょうね うつになっちゃって
そういうのはもうもうあなたはもうもうもう切っちゃったと
もう出て行けっていう意味なんです
もう心配しないと ただまた何言うんでしょうかと
もうすごい苦しいんだと
もう家族はものすごく嫌がっているんだとかね
家族は大変だと もう仕事もできなくなったと
収入もなくなったと どれぐらい？とさらに私は聞くんで
どれぐらいどんなどれぐらい苦しいでしょうかと
そうすると延々と苦しみを言うんです
何者かと その人がそんなにもうつが苦しいならば
嫌であるならば 言うことやればいいでしょうに
やりたくないと わかるでしょ
そうすると 何言ってるかと
治して欲しくないっていうことなんです
だから本当に我々は何者かと分かってないんだから
ガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャもうあれこれやと嘘ばっかり垂らしているんです
しかし 一つも嘘だとは認めないんです
嘘だと言っちゃうとものすごい怒られる
それはすごい難しいことなんです
良い人間のつもりで良い人間になりたいつもりでいることの実体を発見することが今日のテーマです
我々は良い人間でいるつもり
良い人間になりたいつもりですけど
実体は何なのかと そこで人は自分が良い人間だと
良いことをしているのだと思い込んでいる
それが問題なんです これ思い込み
で覚えておください はい
それでどのように騙すのかと
ワンチャカダンマとは悪を善に見せかけることです
パーリ語の専門用語はワンチャカダンマという言葉で
それってのは悪を善に見せかける
だから善に見せかけてるだけだから良くなるはずがないんです
善を悪に見せることはありえない
逆はありえないんです
悪を善に見せかけるんですけど
善は悪に見せかけることはしません
それはありえないし 成り立たないし
やる必要もないんです
[背景の音楽]中身清らかならば行為も清らかです
余談になりますけど 二行目ね
善を悪に見せることはありえないっていうことはちょっとわからないかも
これ難しいんです ものすごい難しいんです
そのポイントは だからちょっとすべらせたいんですけど
それは説明できませんだけど
この ちょっと俗世間のなんと似ている例は出せます
例えば子供のことをすごく心配して
子供に対してカンカン怒るとかね
その場合は怒るということは悪でしょうし
親が本当にいつでも怒りっぱなしで
もうどうしようもない親だなとか子供は思うかもしれません
うちの親はもうとんでもない性格が悪いんだぞと
しかし 親が子供のことをすごい心配して悪いことをさせないようにとやってるとかね
その場合は善を悪として見せかけるようにと見えるでしょう
本当は親は善なんです
子供のことを心配している
そのために怒っていると
だから怒りは悪で 親の心は善で
だから中身は善で表に見せているのは悪ということになるんですが
それは成り立たないんです
本気で怒っているんです
子供のことを心配という気持ちがあると
怒りの仕方が違うんです
すごく違うんです 怒りではなくて
その代わりに冗談とか何とかからくりとか
何とかふざけることとか
何とかに変わるんです
私はいろんな親を見ているんだから
もう本気で怒るんです
でも親だから怒るという瞬間に
またもう怒りが変わったりはするんですけど
でも本気なんです だから失敗しますよ
だから悪は 善はあまり悪を演じないんです
演じる必要もないんです
そういうことで 世の中でよくいい加減な話いっぱいありますよね
いろんな仏教の話もありますね
あの 何て言いますか 法華経
法華経にもそういうエピソードもいい加減なへ理屈のエピソードを話していますけどね
子供をなんか愛しているがゆえに苦しませると
という何か悪い息子のエピソードがあるんです
私もあまり皆さんに紹介するほどは覚えてないんですけど
なんか大金持ちの人が自分の子供をもうだらしない子供がいて
もうどうしようもない
で その人は家を出て あっちこっち苦労して生活してるんだと
それで苦労して苦労して
もうやがて自分の家に戻るんですかと
で 親が随分親切にしてあげると
大金持ちにさせてあげると
そのように本来みんなもう悟っているんだからねという話になりますけど
あんなのはへ理屈のいいところで
インチキなところで 何の話にもなりませんだけど
親が子供のことを心配するがゆえに苦労させると
そこでその法華経の物語で言っている
言ってないのは その性格悪い息子が不良者になって性格良くなったかないか
それは言ってないんです
もし性格良くなったならば理屈成り立ちますけど
ただ疲れ果てて家に帰っただけ
そこで召使いと一緒にいるんだと
自分も何者かわかってないんだと
自分も召使いだと思ってるんだと
そこでもう金持ちの父親がその人を息子だからまた家に連れて行って
もう大変贅沢させてあげるという話なんです
まあストーリーにも何にもなりません
あんなのは あんまりにも頭がおかしい変な人が書いたエピソードだと思いますけどね
そういうことを真面目に読むんだから
読む人はね だからどうにもならんです
だからこの二行目で書いたことは
この善を悪で悪に見せかけることはできない
人にとって優しいんだったら
これは優しいんです それだけ
優しい人に何かこれはダメということは言う場合
ただ単にこれはダメじゃないかというだけのことで
怒りが割り込んでこないんです
相手がわからないなと思ったら
何か寸地に何か面白い工夫が頭に出てくるんですよ
相手のことを憎んでないんだから
あ こう言えばこいつは理解してくれるぞと
そこは面白く 何か話し方が浮かんでくるんです
しかし 我々一般でそうじゃなくて
なんでお前はわかってくれないのかと来るでしょうに
もう怒っているんです
嫌なんです だから悪は悪
悪は善人ぶりますが 善人善人かぶりますけど
善は別に何も被る必要はないんです
善は必ずいい結果出すんだから
何も被る必要ないんですよ
それで三行目のまあ中身が清らかならば
行為も清らかです 人は自分の中身を正当化する
中身は何か分からないんだけど
正当化するんですよ 正しいと思っているんです
で 解脱をしてない限り中身が悪いんです
これがもうもう仏教の話だから
もうそのまま それで何も言うことはないんです
あの本来みんな悟っているんだっていうのは
これは明らかに嘘で 本来みんな悪人なんです
悪人たちを慰めてあげるために
ああいう話をしているのであって
お釈迦様が言ったことではありません
お釈迦様自身で悟る 最初に悟り開いた
もう感染者であるお釈迦様が言ってないことは
なんでそちら中にいる？もうもうだらしない弟子たちに言えるんですかね
ありえないんです だから
人間の本性 本性というかね
まあそれが完璧で仏性だと
如来蔵だというのは もうあの騙し機能のもう一つなんです
あれで見事に人を騙して
あの善人にならないようにしてくれるんです
だから本性は本来 本性は仏性だと
本性はものすごい清らかだという話は聞いて
誰も自分を直そうとしないんです
あの道元禅師さんももう腹が立ったんですよ
あのもう何とかの山にいて
日本でどこでしたっけ
あの比叡山で そちらはもう天台師匠で
もうもうみんなもう悟っているんだそうと
道元禅師もそれなりに
だったらなんで俺たちが苦労して修行しなくちゃあかんかと
本人がすごい正直で もう修行したいという気持ちはあるんですね
でも答えがないんだから中国に行っちゃったんですけどね
中国に行ったらそういう話はなく
禅寺ではいたずら修行しているんです
あれやこれやガチャガチャガチャガチャ哲学も何もない
それで本人もそう それなりの修行して
まあ何か何かわかって帰ったんですけど
でもはっきりはわかってないんです
まだまだ考え方すごい曖昧で
優柔不断で まあいろいろあれやこれやあれやこれあれやこれと言うんですけど
まあ結局でももともと正直な人だから
かなり年取ってからはもうなんとなく落ち着いたみたいですね
まあ最初に書いているものはみんな作品等素晴らしいと思ってますけど
えらい優柔不断で もうはっきり客観的に見るともうおかしい見所なんです
最後に書いたところはそういうこと何もなく
ただ仏教の話の説明 まああの三十七菩提分方の説明とか
そういうごく一般的な仏教に戻りました
ですから この 何でしょうか
この自分を正当化するということは大変大きな問題なんです
だから あの天台師匠などでは
本覚師匠が現れたっても不思議でも何でもないんです
例えばキリスト教になってくると
神様が皆に魂を与えて分けているということで
だからみんなもう魂は持っているというところで
みんな立派な人間やという話は一応言ってはいる
尊い魂を持ってるんではないかと
そこから問題なんです
そこから人殺しに行く
神を信じる人がだけ魂は永遠であって
そうでない人々はもう地獄に落ちるんだと
最初は神様は平等に魂を分けたと言って
次に神様は平等から脱出させちゃって
まあ分別するんですね
もう汚い魂と綺麗な魂と
誰のせいかと聞きたいんですけど
そうなるはずないでしょうね
永遠な魂は汚くなるはずないでしょうに
だからもう何言ってるかと
むちゃくちゃもう矛盾なんですよ
だからもうヒンドゥー教にしたっても
キリスト教にしたって
どちらにしたってイスラム教にしたっても
やっぱりみんないい人間やという態度でもう話始まるんです
それでどうなるかというと
堂々とも何もなくなっちゃって
人間っていうのはそのまんまになるんです
成長 人格向上はなし 神を信じればそれで終わり終了ということになるんです
だからこの正当化することっていうのは大きな問題
ブッダの教えと他の教えとはものすごい違うところ
もう水と油のように違うんです
違うところは この本性が悪だと言っているところなんです
一行で言えば無明 アヴィッジャーなんです
無知 だから解脱をしてない限り
中身が悪い 正当化する必要ないんです
でもこれ一番難しいんですよ
我々には自分を正当化してずっと生きてきたんだから
これはものすごい難しい
あの無理にやったってもダメですよ
精神的におかしくなるんです
俺がダメな人間だとかね
悪人だとか思ってたらとんでもないことになるんです
そう簡単単純なことじゃないんです
だから決して無理にやる必要はないんです
ブッダの方法っていうのは自覚しなさい
それでいきなり答えが出てくるんです
ああ そうかと 納得しなさいよと
納得するまで喋りますよと
納得するまで質問しなさいよと
ああ 事実はそうなのかと納得した時点で解決方法がそちらにあるんです
問題はありません だからもうごまかして
無理に強引に 私がやっぱり悪い人間だと思ったっても
何の効き目もないんです
はい 中身をそのままにしておいて良い人間になろうとするから問題です
中身というのは 本心 本音というものが正しいと思っているから
善を演じる羽目になるのです
我々は中身は悪なんですよ
中身は悪ですけど それ正当化しているでしょうに
自分の本当の気持ちは正しいと思っているでしょう
だから善を演じるんです
善を行ってるんじゃないんです
行うことと演じるは違うんです
[紙の音]例えば ぎ-議題-時代劇とか何とか見ると
あの 天皇とかそういう役演じるでしょ？誰かが
随分かっこよく だってすっごい能力のある俳優さんたちですからね
彼らは演じるんですよ
見事に ものの見事に しかし
本物もいるんですけど
日本で 天皇陛下という
何も演じてないんです
ただ行っているだけ ごく普通の服を着て
ごく普通の まあそんなにド派手でもない
まあごく一般的な制服を着て
一般的に歩いて ごく一般的な人々と話して
一般的にお辞儀をして
全くの一般的で 全くも一般的な人間で
で もう帰るんです で 本物の天皇陛下は演じてるわけじゃないんです
ただ自分の公務を行っているだけ
だからどちらが効き目があるのかと
ドラマでは演じているんです
しかし 本物と比べるとものの見事に演じる人の方が上手なんです
[笑い]発音やら言葉の使い方やら
何から何まで完璧上手
上手で だからこの演じることと行うことっていうのはかなり違うっていうことを理解してほしい
だから善を演じる人がものの見事に演じるんです
行う場合はそんなに ごく普通なんです
これできれば天皇陛下の例ででも考えて覚えてください
本物の場合は全然もうただ普通じゃないかと
えーと 善を演じている限り性格は向上しない
まあ演じるものは本物じゃないんだからね
まあ本物にはなりません
いくら演じても だから俳優さんは一生俳優さんで
決して王になることはないんです
一生王の役を演じたっても王にはなりません
善を演じるとは誰も思っていません
問題はそれを思ってないんです
全ての人間が本当に善を演じているんですけど
そう思ってない いいことをしていると思ってるんです
従って 具体的な説明になると皆機嫌が悪くなる
傷つく ということで あまり仏教で扱わないテーマにしているんです
はい まあ一応一部はそれで終了だと思います
それから具体的に あの
説明に入ります ワンチャカダンマ
自分自身を巧妙に巧妙に騙す
ごまかす 心の働きについての具体的な説明
しかし この全部できませんので
一部のみなんです なぜ全部できないかというと
まずすっごく難しい 言ってる人も間違う可能性あります
仏教の本というのはこの無数に印刷されています
仏教本の本というのは日本語で少ないかもしれませんだけど
英語 フランス語 ドイツ語は結構あります
そこでミャンマー スリランカ
タイやらもうまたずっと書いてるんです
自分の国でもかなり英語でもシンハラ語でもたくさんの本を出してます
昔から あれは昔から出した本を全てまとめたらかなり量でしょうに
しかし このワンチャカダンマについてあるのはたったこの一冊だけなんです
これに2番目の本も出てないんです
書けないんです この本書いたお坊さんはもう本当にすごい立派な方で
まあ信じられないほど人格者で
たくさんの本を書いたんです
で この本を書いて まあこの序論で
こうやってこの騙す機能について私にわかるように
私に私が理解できるように書きましたけど
もしかすると私も騙されている可能性ありますよと
自分も騙されて説明するところもあるかもしれませんから
よく気をつけて読んでくださいと
そういうところを見つけたら
自分の理解で判断してくださいということで
その本書く場合でも こんな立派なお坊様なんですけど
今亡くなってますけどね
で そこまで言うんです
それぐらい巧妙なんです
この騙す機能っていうのは
特に出家がすごく気に気をつけなくちゃいけないこと
で 世界世間にあるんだけど
一旦出家するのは解脱するために出家するんですよ
だから甘えてはいけないんですね
自分には で 良い人間になろうとすればするほど
騙し機能がものすごい巧妙に働くんです
だからはっきり言うと
たくさん騙されているのは誰かというと
出家の方が多い 一般の人々より
一般の人々は悟ろうとか全然考えてもないんだから
もうただ美味しいものを食べて年取るまで元気でいればいいというぐらいでしかもう望みがないんだから
もうあんまり騙す必要ないんです
悟ろうというと ものすごい期待が違うでしょうに
だから騙す機能っていうのは
一般人よりも厳しく機能するのは出家世界なんです
だから この例は全部皆様に紹介することもできないし
専門用語はむちゃくちゃ出てくるし
で 出家だけの世界に限ったものもたくさん出てくるし
そういう難しさもありますけど
まあまあ適当に一部だけ説明していきます
で この騙すということは
我々のまずは方程式を覚えておきましょう
我々の本性が悪 本性って本音っていうのは悪の塊
仏教では煩悩 その煩悩があるんだから
煩悩 悪が善を演じる だからどのように演じるかという場合は
煩悩一つ一つ取って それがどんな風に巧妙に人を騙すかと説明しなくちゃいけないんです
煩悩はいくつあるかというと
残念なことにあるんです
1500は省略すると 3つになりますけど
貪瞋痴だと しかし 貪瞋痴と言っただけで
全ての心の働きはわかるわけじゃないんです
貪りも 500であって
500種類 怒りも 500種類
無知も 500種類にして 1500なんです
だから騙す機能っていうのは具体的に説明するっていうことはもう無理不可能な話で
こちらでもほんの一部しか扱ってないし
それから誰かがさらに研究して明確に書いてくれるだろうとその先生書いてるんですけど
誰も書こうとはしないし
書ける能力ある人もスリランカではいないと思いますけど
一部一部説明して これからこの欲の縁
欲が騙す このお坊さんがこの場合欲と言っているのは
この一般的な世間の欲だけなんです
で  1番目パラッタカーマタ
パラッタカーマタっていうのは
パラッタっていうのは他人のことですね
もう他人のために尽くしたくないんですよ
福祉に興ずるんですけども
もう他人のために尽くしたい
本当は演じています 尽くしたくないんです
どういうことかと 他人を助けることは素晴らしい善行為です
それは善行為です その行いをする人々は
社会に認められる 賞賛される
成功する 様々な利益を得る
これに惹かれるのです
世の中を見ると 人を助ける人々はすごい立派ですね
親の面倒を見ない日本人がどれほどいたと思いますか？インドのマザーテレサのところに
それで善人だと思っているんです
自分の親の面倒は全然見ない
あちらに行って一生懸命頑張る
1年  2年とか 騙されています
あれはマザーテレサの
あの 何て言いますか 大変有名ですからね
それに惹かれていくんです
それで自慢する 私にも反論までされましたから
私はね マザーテレサのところにも
もう毎年毎年 もう 10回まで 10年間も行っていたんだよと
私は別に褒めることもできん
そうですか それは良かったということしかできんだからね
でもだらしないのだらしないんだからね
何ヶ月間あちらで仕事をしたっても
福祉活動をしたっても
そういうことなんです
だからといって だからといって
まず人々を助けること悪いわけじゃないんですよ
だから問題は 本当に良いことをするならば
まず人々が助けられたことになるし
本人も人格者になるはずなんです
あの因果法則から見れば
助ければ助けるほど助けられる状態になるはずなんです
それがないでしょう 助けられた人は一人もいない
結局は でもノーベル賞をもらうところまで人助けはする
助けられた人はゼロという状態なんです
社会から賞賛されることで喜びを感じて頑張る
しかし 自分の行為を全く知らないならば
何もしない これはちょっと日本語が分かりません
例えば全くも知らないところで行って
そういうことはしないんです
マザー・テレサぐらいの有名な人でなきゃいけないんです
そこら辺で どこかで 誰も知らないところで人が困っている時は
もう平気であっち向く
振り向くんです その人を助けたっても
別に自分に何の利益もないんだと
危ないんだと ちゃんとした有名なところで
組織 何かに入っていなきゃ駄目ですよと
そう でも でも本当にいい娘さんがいるのはテレビで見たんですけど
彼女がいろいろタイとかいろんなところのいろんな福祉なんかに行ってきて
で このホームレスの面倒見るんですね
で 本当に娘さんで若いし
で 結構苦労してやっている
で このやり方を見ると
ものすごい 何て言いますかね
何も違和感もなく すごい視線に入って
そのおじいさんたち おばあさんたちに話
まあほとんどおじいさんたちだけどね
話をかけて 一言葉も強引にも言わないし
で 一人のおじいさんがこの「人の助けはもらいたくない」と
ものすごい頑固なんです
そこでもうもう寒い冬なんですけど
雨が降ってるんです で
何か傘をさして夜ベンチで座っているんです
考えてください 冬 雨が降っている
それで夜ベンチで座っている
寝ることも何もできん
雨が降るっていうことを知って
彼女が何かこのすごい暖かいシート
何かこのピカピカしている何か特別なシートなんですけど
あれかなり防寒機能あるみたいんです
薄いんですけど それがあって
それを持ってきて もうさっさとそこを走っていったんです
みんな困ってるんだと
で いろんな人に配って
一番このおじさんのことを心配して
そばに行って本人も一緒に座って 「
これがこうやって体にかぶっちゃえばもう暖かくなるんだよ」と
いらんと言うんですね
いらんと言ったら 本当に娘さんのような感じで
もうおじいさんの床 外に座って
自分でそれすっとかぶって 「
こういう風な感じだよ」と 「
おじいさん そうするとすごい暖かくなるんだよ」と
で 受け取らない それで 「
では あの 置いておきますから
あの もし あの 欲しかったら使ってください」と言って彼女は帰るんです
あんまり強引にも言わない
ああ この子だけは正直だなと
それで私もすごい感動したんですね
なんか強引に 例えば「何だ
そんなこと言ったらもう風邪引いちゃうでしょう」と
まあ風邪引いちゃうと言ったんですけど
おじいさん風邪引いちゃうでしょうね
そういう そういう感じで
でも相手に気分に損なうことっていうのは一つもしないで
ただ心配だけあってね
すごく美しかったんです
で 普通は世の中でこの有名なところだったら
ちゃんとした世界的なNGO組織なんとかだったらもう頑張るんであって
そこら辺どこかって言ったら頑張らないというね
だからまあそこは善を演じる
本人がいいことをすると 「
ああ 気分がいいんだ まあみんなに認められるんだ
賞賛されるんだ」という 「
ああ これで私は一生この仕事をするんだぞ」とかね
言ったりもする でも本物とは違う
まあ私はいくつかケースは名前知らないだけで
日本人の方々 本物で人助ける人々っていうのは知ってますけど
テレビの番組をいろいろ見てね
で もうびっくりするほど本物で
もう本当にもう人を助ける
例えばこの砂漠緑化する運動やらね
もう必死でコソコソコソコソコソコソとやっているとかね
何の利益もない 何の組織もない
でも なんとかしてその人々と一緒に
外から援助は置いておいてやるんです
その場合でも この人々と一緒にやると
それは本当にその人々のものになるんだよと
でも そういう人々は全然ノーベル賞をもらわないんです
大きな組織に入ってないんだから
はい で ダートゥカーマタっていうのは
この人にものを与えたいっていうこと
[背景音楽]分け与えたり
与える 施すは欲という不善心想をなくす善行為です
お釈迦様は与えることを推薦しているのです
何のためかというと この心の中にある一つの悪を退治させるためなのです
欲という汚いものが本性に入っているのです
この本性からその欲という汚いものを追い出すために
施ししなさいと言っているのです
もしそのために施し行為するならば
善を演じているんじゃなくて修行しているのです
自分を改良するために
でも そのために施しする人っていうのはほとんどこの世の中にないのです
しかし 他人にものを与える人は好かれる
人気者になる 皆 自分が言うことを聞いてくれる
自分に従う これを与えることの善果だと勘違いして
この善行為に没頭する
しかし 欲を磨く悪行為なのです
それで一般的に人にものを与えると
みんな喜ぶし 自分を信頼するし
自分を何か言ったら 自分ちょっと何か困ったことがあったらさっさと来て助けてくれるし
人にものを与える人 何か頼んだらすぐやってくれますから
みんな結局気分がいいんです
その人は思うんです 私がいいことをやってるんだから
このいい結果があるんだよと
私はこの国でなかなか知られているんだと
なぜかというと 私は億単位でいろんな施しをしているんだからと
それが善行為 お布施の結果ではないかと本人が思う
でもこれがちょっとではなくて
かなり違うんです 施しっていうことは何のためにあるのかというと
心にある欲という あの細菌を追い出すためなんです
それが考えようともしないんです
えらい気分が良くて 人気者になって
有名になって 一生懸命人にものを与えたりする
だから結局は悪行為なんです
だから世の中で人を助ける
人にものを与える人っていうのはいくらでもいるんだけど
世の中は一向に良くならないんです
そこで日本の新興宗教のカテゴリーにしたっても
ご利益 ご利益 ご利益 商売繁盛ばっかり言ってるでしょうに
そんなことしなく言わなかったらお金が入らないんです
だから宗教組織っていうのは
一応ある一つの商売なんです
だから人間の心の悪さっていうのは
宗教そのものまで腐ってしまったんです
だから日本人が宗教をものすごく汚染して
日本人がかえって悪く
言うんです 宗教なんか信じませんよとか言いながら信じる
この麻原のケースでも
テレビで喋るは喋るは麻原が間違っている
こういう時点で間違っているということは
言える人は一人も知識人の中でいないんです
よっぽど頭が悪いなと私は思うんです
だから二度とそういう現象が起こらないようにということは全然できない
麻原のサリンケースで日本人が何を勉強したかというと
何一つもないんです それからもそういうインチキ宗教はいくらでも現れてきたんだから
麻原のグループは未だにやってるんだから
未だに元気 だからどうなっているのかと
だから禅というのはひとかけらもないんです
ただ お寺 神社 仏閣に行っても
何かご利益くれという
誰かが病気になったら
もう誰かが試験を受けるならば行くんであって
あるいは誰かが死んじゃったらお化けになって首を絞めたら困るぞということで行くんであって
決して清らかな気持ちで穏やかな気持ちで行くわけじゃないんです
まああまり普通お寺ご利益なんか売ってないんだから
お寺はただお墓で生きているでしょうに
神社はご利益で生きているでしょうし
新興宗教はご利益で見事な商売をやっているでしょうし
で お墓参りに来る人はお墓にしがみついてるだけであって
この宗教って何だと このお寺は何を教えているところか
もう最低宗派何かもわからないんです
ただ うちのお墓はあのお寺にあるんだからというだけで
だからこのものを与えるということは
心理学的に言えば なんで善行になるのかというと
与えることでそのものに依存する性格がなくなる
欲が減る 欲が減ったということは
心は一部綺麗になったということなんです
それで心の一部綺麗になると智慧が現れてくる
智慧が現れると 完全に綺麗にするためにどうすればいいかということもわかる
施しでどこまで綺麗になるのかと
このリミットまでわかる
施ししてもしても 完全に心は綺麗になるわけじゃないんだと
ここまでだと それもわかる
わかって どんどん人格向上していくんです
正しくやれば それは自分を忘れて人を助けてではないかというふうに先人ぶっちゃうんです
冗談でしょう 人を助けると
何様のつもりですかね
何ができると思ってるんですかね
自分自身が助けてもらう状態にいるのに
自分自身の心がもう悪の塊なのに
人を助ける あり得るんですかね
だから私はすごい変なことばっかし言ってるでしょ
みんな私の口癖だと思ってますけど
口癖もないわけじゃないんだけど
実際の真理っていうのはそういうかなりきついものなんです
世の中の知識とは全然合わないんです
だからこの自分のことを置いておいて
他人を救うという概念ほど恐ろしい概念はないんです
でも 我々にはすごく耳障りの言葉なんです
自分もそうなりたい気持ちになるんです
では 私も人が片っ端から救ってやろうではないかとか
それ先にブッダ聞くのはちょっと待てと
君は何者かと まず自分を見ろと
だから自分ができてもないのに
悪の塊なのに 悪の塊の人格者がやることを全て悪行為でしょうに
だから人助けじゃなくてえらい社会迷惑なんです
私達は知らん知らんうちでそういう福祉やってるんです
だからもう信じられないほど人類っていうのは騙されてるんです
自分自身で だから人はいろんな人は人にものを与えてますよ
与えてるんだけど 仏教によると
与える人が真っ先に幸福になるはずなんです
でも幸福にならないんです
例えばブッダの場合はある村に行っただけで十分なんです
行っただけでものすごい圧倒されちゃって
みんなの心はきれいになるんです
見ただけでも そういう人はその印象がもう焼き付けちゃって天国に行くんです
だからその謂れで我々はいるところをあっちこっち仏像だらけにするんです
それは偶像崇拝じゃないんです
昔からある謂れなんです
ブッダを見ただけでも
その姿が頭に焼き付くんだと
それで心がきれいになるんだと
そこでワイシャリという国にお釈迦様が行ったら
そのあれは何国家でしたっけ？共和国
だから議会で政治やっているんです
王様ではないんです お釈迦様はこの議会場で泊まるんですよ
そうするとえらい迷惑でしょうに
議会の王様たちが集まれませんし
何のこともない お釈迦様いる間では政治はなし
で 大勢の人々はその劇場に入って説法を聞いたりする
で 議員さんとは言わない
なぜならば選挙で選べたわけじゃないんだから
もう王子と言うんですけど
その王子たちが まあたちもそっちを行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり お釈迦様の話を聞いたり
それで国がきちんと統一されます
お釈迦様の説法だけで
誰も犯罪も起こすことはないし
あれこれとやることも何もない
それだけで だからお釈迦様いる間は憲法も入りませんし
何もいらないということになるんです
政治もいらなくなる それぐらい人々は良い人間になる
だからお釈迦様はもう一年しか
三ヶ月間しか一箇所にいらっしゃらないし
それでみんな泣くんですね
またもう寂しくなるんだと
だから本物っていうのはそういうものなんです
そんなに人を育てることは難しいわけじゃないんです
人格向上させるとか こう難しいことじゃないんです
それで問題はお釈迦様は方法を教えて教え残したんだけど
私たちはどこかで勘違いというか間違いか何か変なんですね
我々は自分を置いといて世界世直ししようではないかということに言っちゃうんです
そこはもう問題で そこで結局は善行のはずで善行だと言えないものをやっているんです
でも完全に悪い結果になるということはないんだけど
良い結果にはならないんですね
[咳]また かたんよってたという言葉があります
かちゃんよってたっていうのはなかなか日本語の言葉もないんですけど
かたんよっていうのは
人が自分にしてくれたことをよく覚えている性格って意味なんです
だから まあ慈恩という言葉もありますが
まあそれは直訳で でも慈恩と言ったってもあんまりわからないし
恩返しと言ったらちょっともうまた意味が下がっちゃうしね
恩返しでもないんです
慈恩なんですけど 他人が自分にしてくれたことをよく理解して覚えていることなんです
その結果として恩返しもするという
だから恩返しって言っちゃうとできる場合もできない場合もありますから
例えば親に恩返しするのは
親が生きている間でしょうに
親が亡くなったらできんでしょうに
そうではなくて 一生親の恩を大事にする
覚えておく で 親孝行 恩師孝行とか今書きましたけど
それはパーリ語で我々にもある言葉で
日本語ではないと疑ってハテナ入れておいたんです
で 私たちの場合は恩師に対する孝行も親孝行と同じ大事なんです
特に出家世界では親がいないんだから
親代わりもすべて師匠なんですね
だからものすごい一生懸命面倒を見るなどをすると
相手がとても喜んで さらに自分の方面倒を見る
これは人間の普通の働きで
自分の子供が一生懸命親のことを心配して面倒見てくると
親がもう舞い上がって
もう楽しくて楽しくてたまらんですよ
それは親の心理学でそうなるんです
親っていうのはあまり変な人で
もうただお母さんのこと
お父さんのことは世界一好きですよと言っただけで十分なんです
さんざん自分をいじめてあったでも
それでももう全部取り消しするんですよ
子供がやった悪いこと
まあそれぐらいのものなんで
親っていうのは 一番世の中でこの納得させやすい
楽しませやすい 喜ばせやすい二人といえば両親なんですね
大馬鹿者と言いますけど
もう子供がちょっとしたことをしたら
まあこれです もう信じられないほど喜ぶ
それで子供が親孝行やら
恩師の場合も同じなんです
インド スリランカやら我々文化の場合は
もう先生も先生で もう弟子たちに対してはすごい我が子のようにも大事にする
心配する だからすごい雰囲気はいいんです
そうやって恩師に対する孝行をする場合は
もう先生も結構踏ん張るんです
弟子のために それに惹かれて親孝行する
親が自分のことを褒めまくるわ
先生も自分のことを褒めまくるわ
もうよく親切にしてくれる
これは気分がいいんですよ
これで親孝行したりする
自分が良い人間だと勘違いまでする
親 で それはまあ それもよくあることで
本当は親の恩知ってる
知ってやってるわけじゃなくて
親の面倒見ると 親の反応を見ると
親の面倒見て親の反応を見ると
もう信じられないぐらいの反応なんです
そうするともう世界でも頂点になって自分が喜ぶんです
親孝行したいと思う それだからこんな楽しいことはあるのかということで
もうとことんとことん親孝行する
時々いますよ 例えば親孝行しようと
若い時も男とかね まあもう母親の父親の面倒見ちゃうと
もうこれ無茶を喜ぶでしょ
向こうは それで一生面倒見るんで結婚もしないで
私は結婚してる なんでかって
やっぱり結婚したらもう親孝行できなくなるんだ
結局は自分の一生は無茶苦茶
もう無茶苦茶というわけではないんですけど
常識的な生き方はできなくなっちゃうんです
そこまで親孝行っていうのは人の心を惹かれるんですよ
やってみるとそんな楽しいことはないんです
それほど でもそれで仏教のこのもう誰にも言わない心理学の立場から見ると
あんた騙されてるんだと欲に
あんた欲を満たしてるだけやと
親孝行というのはそのためにあるものじゃないんです
自分のすべてが借り物やと
人の慈しみによって自分が成り立っているんだと
自分が何者でもないんだと
ただ支えられて生きてきたものだと
そういうことを自覚するために恩返しをするんです
絶対恩を だから仏教では親
親孝行しなさいではなくて
恩を知りなさいという言葉にしているんです
親孝行するという言葉と恩を知るという言葉にはものすごい差があるんです
だから仏教なんか日本訳しても
みんなあんまり惹かれないんですよ
なんかつまらないんではないかと
これよりは老師 孟子誰でしたっけ？中国の孔子が素晴らしく親孝行なんと何孝行とは書いているんではないかとか
だからアホなことを書いているんだから
韓国でも日本でも中国でも孔子の考え方は実行する
欲を満たすことを考えているんだから
どうったことないんです
親は馬鹿だからね ほんのちょっともう何かしてあげればね
もう無茶喜ぶますよ でも親の喜びは本物だから
子供にしてみればものすごい楽しくなっちゃうんですね
それで これに乗っちゃうんです
これがダメですよ それでは
自分の人格を直すためにやらなくちゃいけないんです
自分が良い人間になるためにやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから結局一生かけて親孝行をやる人々も
大した人格者じゃないんです
親孝行する子でなんか選挙にも出て勝った
ある一人いますね うん
まあ一旦議員になったからはとんでもないだらしないことばっかしで
もう議員になる前は立派なことを言っていたんですけどね
だからそれだけでは人格者にはなれないんです
ただ誰とも同じことなんです
あっちもうちょっと言い忘れちゃった
時々子供が親の財産狙って
例えば大学ではもう仕事を狙って親孝行
先制孝行する場合もあります
それがこのこちらに入りません
なぜかというと それはもう狙ってやっていることだから
本人知ってますからね
親の財産は自分に欲しくて
ずっと親の面倒を見ると
心の中知ってますからね
自分が親はどうでもいいやと思ってますけど
やっぱり財産は自分に名義変更しない限りはということで面倒見る
そこは今日のテーマではありません
そんなのはもう分かりきったことで
あの 自分を騙す機能ではないんです
この人は自分を騙されているんです
自分が本当にいい人間だと思っているんです
本当にいい人間で 親のために過ごしているんだと思っているんです
親の財産なんかはもう財産もないんだと
親には 親が亡くなったら財産全部どこかに寄付したいんだと
そこまで言うんです もしかするとそれをやるんです
親が亡くなったら親のためにと言って
全て財産は寄付するとか
そこまでやるんですが
騙されているんです はい
次に行きます アパチティカーマタ
このアパチタっていうのは
これもあまり日本ではあんまり関係ない
これはまああの仏教の世界であることで
常にこの目上の人を尊敬するということ
で 私たちの場合はこれ大変な出来事で
出家の中でいつでも年上の人を礼をしたり尊敬したりしなくちゃいけないし
いつでも一歩下がっていなくちゃいけないし
で まあこれはまあ結構やりますけどね
両親を恩師 参謀などを尊敬することですが
結果として褒めてもらうこと
得をすること 特別扱いされることを期待する
自分が謙虚な人間だと思う
しかし 欲が潜んでいるのです
で 例えばまあもう仏像やらお寺やら見ただけでもう合掌するわとかね
よくありますけど えらいこの気持ち悪いんですけどね
もう感じますから これは本物じゃないんだと
で これも見たらもう一生懸命礼をするはするわとか
かなり時間かけて俺が礼をしているんではないかということは
見せつけるために結構時間までかかるんです
なんでそういうか 私はすっごくそれで嫌な気持ちをしょっちゅう味わいますから
勝手にすればいいんだけど
こちらの時間まで食うなよと
初めから迷惑やと やっぱり
それで自分がちゃんと物事をよく知っている
行儀よく知っている きちんとしけたり知っている人間だと自己自賛したいんです
それで一生懸命やる でも結局自己自慢したいだけの話でいい人間にはなれません
はい 次行きます アヌクーラタ
これもなかなか日本語の単語はないんですが
まあ従うという意味は従うぐらいのことで
これは仏教では大変大事ないいことなんです
アヌクーラタっていうのは
で 人間というのは不完全ですから
完全な人の真似しないと
完全な人に従わないと完全にならないんです
だからいつでもモデルに合わせて自分を作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
俺が誰のモデルにもしないぞと思ったら
もうそれで終わりですから
人生は だから仏教では
この人格向上するために必要な素晴らしい道徳のリストの中で
一つはアヌクーラタなんです
従うっていうこと しかし
それを大きな声で言えなくなっちゃう
何か従いなさいと言ったら何かカッコ悪いんですよ
その一般的に言うもう私言うことに従いなさいという風な汚い意味じゃないんです
俺言うことを聞けという態度じゃないんです
仏教にあるのは人格向上するために
自分という人格があって
完璧な人格があって それに比較して
これもあれに従うようにするんです
そうすると自分も完璧な人格者になるんです
その意味の従いなんです
だからそれ真似かもしれません
例えば皆様にヴィパッサナー瞑想させようとさせる時は何させているかというと
この悟った人の心の状況の真似なんです
何にもとらわれない生き方の真似なんです
あれ真似事 その真似事をやっていると
正しくやるならば この偽善でやっちゃうとできませんだけど
正しくやればゆっくりゆっくり
じわじわじわじわとあのモデルに近寄っていく
近づいていくんです そこで真似しているんだっていうこと
消えちゃうんです それでもう悟ってるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想とは
純粋にこの悟った人の心の状況の真似なんです
だからたくさんの法もないんです
それでこの私たち出家は何やるかというと
全部真似です 何から何まで
で なんで真似するんでしょうかというと
この本気で真似をしている間で
知らん知らんうちに自分の人格が向上していくんです
だからそれはもう避けられない善
人間やらなくちゃいけない修行なんです
従うということ アヌクーラタ
でも問題は この これ喋れないんですよ
説明できないし 従いなさいと言ったら
もう何でもかんでも従うことだと
そんな意味じゃないんです
無批判で無差別で 人いうことを何でも聞けという
そんな話じゃないんだから
仏教は ブッダさえも誰にも何の命令もしてないでしょうに
ブッダは殺生するあれではなくて
殺生しない方がいいんだよというだけで
しかしお釈迦様は全くの殺生しない
それで私たちはもうお釈迦様の真似をしようとする
そういう従えなんです
そこでお釈迦様に言われたことは
まあどうせお釈迦様だから
どうせ悟ってる人だから
どうせ完全な人だから
もう別にどうでもいいんだから真似真似ましょうと
ごちゃごちゃ言わずに
どうせ正しいんだからという態度なんです
それで 何も知らん私もそのうちよくいい人間になるんではないかということで
この真似っていうというか
もう従うっていうこと
必ずしも必要な性格なんです
いい人間になるためには
これが知ってるお坊さんたちやら
よく演じるんです それ誰にでも
まあこれ皆様にわかるように軽くしたんです
はいはい主義者という言葉を作ったんですけど
そうした方がわかりやすい
だからこの従うということで
何でもはいはいはいはいとか何でもやる
逆らわない でも今日は無理ですよ
先生言っても明日どうでしょうかって
何でもはいはいはいと言って
無理までして今日の分やってあげたりとかね
そうしたら先生から見れば
この人はすごく無理をしたな
私の頼みをやってくれるために
明日やったってもよかったのにとかね
心配するんです いるんですよ
出家の中でも 結構無理をまでして言ったことはやる
私も一回無理をして先生が言ったことをやったことはありますけど
それはその意味ではなかったんです
で まあ子供頃でしたけど
出家したら遊んではいけないんです
なのに隠れて誰かの自転車に乗って
もう行ったところでいきなりブレーキが利かなくなっちゃって
倒れちゃっ怪我しちゃったんです
これ言えないでしょうに
もう隠れてやったことだから
痛くても全部怪我隠してもう体動かないほど痛いんです
でいて夜長老がもうどこかへ行って
もう結構夜なんですけど
明かりをランプを当時電気もなかったし
昔だからね これでもかなり年だから私も
で 明かりをつけて この本堂のお釈迦様のなんとかちょっとってあの修理しなくちゃいけない
でお寺の修理はだいたい長老が自分の手で全部やるんです
その時長老はすごい年だから
手もちょっと震えるんです
で ちょっと右手はアルツハイマーみたいで動くんです
だからそういうきめ細かい仕事はちょっとできない
それで私を引っ張るんですね
いきなり「君 じゃあ行きましょう」と
もう行けないんですけど
こっち寝たい 寝転がっちゃうんですけど
言えないんだから まあコソコソと行って
もうもう全部頼んだことは全部やったんです
もう 11時まで だから悪いことしたら悪い結果はもうすぐ来る
で その場合は自分が無理をしたのは別に先生にいい顔をしたわけじゃなくて
自分が悪いことしたんだから
それ隠したかっただけ
だからそういうことではなくて
ただ頼んだことは無理をして無理をしてやって
先生にいい顔をする それで先生も本気になって相手のことを心配する
私は教えた時でも まあこれこれちゃんと勉強しなさいと言ったら
もう頭が全く悪い 何人かがいて
頭が悪い割にはいつでも本を開けているんです
朝見たっても本を読んでいる
ちゃんと私が言った本を読んでいる
昼見たっても読んでいる
夜も読んでいる でも授業になってくると何一つわかってない
だからもうどうにもならなくなっちゃう
叱ることもできなくなっちゃうし
他の連中はもうもう 1 日中遊ぶ遊ぶ悪いことばっかりやってれば
それでもなんとかなんとか授業中では怒られないようになんとかそれもそれなりにする
だからただ言うことをやっただけでっていう結果もないんですけど
とにかくこのはいはい主義者っていうのは結構生きやすいんですね
この世の中で トラブルは起こりませんし
みんなに好かれるし そこでみんな簡単にはいはい主義者になるんです
そこでいい人間かぶっちゃって
みんなに称賛されてだらしないままで死ぬ
だから世の中でこの何でも聞いてくれる連中がいると
かえって危険でしょうに
例えば大学から言えば
東大生ってのは一番危険でしょう
だっていい親から見てもいい子で
先生から見ても頭が良くてよく勉強する子で
ああいう人々はいはい主義者なんです
だから無意味な東大に入られる
そうすると役にも立たない研究
むちゃくちゃ難しい研究ばっかりやって何も役に立たないし
社会ではいいことをしたケースは全然ないんだから
結局はオウムに入るんだから
あれで頭がいいんですかね
そこで公務員になったらもう不正やると言えばもうもう警察
警視庁からはみんなもうみんな立派な人々ですけど
何やるかというとあんなもんなんです
だからはいはい主義者っていうのは
従うことは素晴らしいことなのに
これではダメですよ これが自分がいい人間だと自分を騙してるだけで
頭がいいんだ だから東大に入ったんだと自分を騙してるだけで
本当は頭が悪いんです
だからはいはい主義者だけでやったらもうそんなに難しくはないんです
どんな大学に入ることでも
時々私も言うんです なんか早く早く合格してあげて
だったらもうあんたごちゃごちゃ言わなくてね
はいはい主義者になれと
でもそれが明らかに相手を騙すっていうことをわかってほしいと
ものを済んだら理解しなさいと
ピーバーディタ ピーバーディタっていうのはこの相手に優しい言葉を語ることで
これで悪く使う場合 美辞麗句主義者主義者とも言ってもいいしね
これ仏教では大変大事な修行の一つなんです
愛語を語れと 何のためにお釈迦様が愛語を語れとおっしゃっているかというと
自分の感情のコントロールをするために
他人の気持ちも理解するために
このわがまま 怒り そういうものを抑えるためなんです
自分言いたいことはベチャベチャ言う人は
自分の心も理解していないし
相手の心も理解していないんです
そんなものだったら永久的に治らないんです
だから言葉を喋る場合はすごく自己観察して
言葉を選んで 相手に対する傷つかない優しい言葉で語る
明確に語る 言葉を選んで
選んで 理解するかしないか
理解しているかないか
そこもチェックしながら語る
それが愛語の決まりなんです
だから愛語を使うと 実践すると
必ずしも自分の人格が向上するはずなんです
そのための大事な修行なんですけど
これが騙されて使うんですよ
なぜかというと 他に対して優しい言葉を使うのは当たり前のことです
それによって自己の我がまま
怒りなど感情が制御する
しかし 相手を貶すことなく
丁寧な美しい優しい言葉を語ると確実に受けるのです
例えば 自分がすごいかっこいい素晴らしい単語を使って語ると
相手がものすごい受けるんですよ
あれは話術 そこで結局は話術をやる
本人が愛語だと本気で思っているんです
自分が愛語を使っているんだから
自分には人気がある 自分言うことを人は聞く
ボスの中で結構いるんです
言葉は随分鍛錬も洗練されて
美しく正しく それでかなり人気者になるんです
お釈迦さんはこういうボスたちは自分たちを騙しているんだと
愛語を語るために 自分の心にいろんな針が刺すはずなんです
愛語を語っている間で
自分の感情やら自分のいろんな気持ちやら
それは制御されちゃって
いろいろ抑えられちゃって
相手の気持ちも考えたりして
それで慈悲が働くわ 智慧が働くわ
結構内面的にはかなり厳しい苦行なんですよ
愛語を語るということは
簡単じゃないんです だから人格向上するんです
それじゃなく 話術で攻撃する
で見事に相手も受ける
だから聞く相手から見れば何のことなく美しい言葉だから
みんなすごいニコニコ笑って穏やかな気持ちになると
それで本人が勘違いする
自分が愛護しているんだから
善行為しているんだから善を変えているんだと
だから人気あるのは当たり前だと
みんなに称賛されるのは当たり前だと言って
そっち寄り乗ってしまうんです
欲なんです だから結局は修行しているつもりなんですが
悪業やってるんです だから何年経っても人格はそのままで終わらないんです
涅槃マカーマタっていうのは出家したいという気持ちなんです
で 出家したいということは素晴らしいことなんです
それが俗世間 世間から離れたい
心平安に持ちたい 集中したい
あれやってこれやってとか
例えば家族がいると もう家族に責任あるんだから人に暇がないんですよ
仕事があると仕事という責任があるんだから
そう 馬鹿 усоひかって生きていられない
だから自分の心は育てられなくなっちゃうんです
それで全ての仕事から
全てのことから離れて心を穏やかにしたいという
だから無欲の欲から離れるって意味なんです
それで無欲は欲をなくすまま書いてありますが
知恵を表す善行為です
しかし 俗世間に未練がない人
修行したがる人などは
世間からよく称賛される
尊敬される 信頼される
それに惹かれて無欲主義になる
そこである人が世間を見ると
出家する人は称賛されるわ
欲が少ない人は褒められるわ
では俺もやってみようではないかと
思っちゃうんです しかし
それが偽善 騙されている
そのための努力じゃないんです
すごい微妙なんです ちょっと次にちょっと伸ばして
じゃあまた戻ります えーと
書いてあったっけ 覚えてない
例えば結婚したいと思ってはいるんですけど
どんどん相手がないし
みんなに嫌われるし モテないし
で 結婚適齢期もなくなっちゃう
男にしたって 女にしたっても同じことですけど
それで独身主義者になって
私はそういう家族を持って
そういうもう煩わしい生き方は嫌いだと
一人でいるのは素晴らしいことだと言うんです
本気で言うんです ただ
相手見つからなかっただけではないかということもには気づかないんです
だからそういう独身主義者は善を悟ったわけないでしょ
一人も人格を向上したわけでもないでしょうに
はい で カルナのこと カルナっていうのはメッタカルナ
ムディタウペッカの2番目
慈悲喜捨の2番目 で そこでも哀れみかぶりと書いたんですけど
カルナ自体カルナでロブ欲が騙されるんですね
欲がカルナのかぶりで来る
本当は欲なんです カルナっていうのは苦しんでいる人を助けるのがカルナです
しかし 欲に騙されている人の場合は
可愛い美しいと思われる人の悩みだけ見える
汚くて醜くて見たくもない人の悩みなんかは気にもしない
だから猫が本当に可愛いんだったら飼っちゃう野良猫
しかし 目が一つないわ
耳がないわとか 怪我して足1本ないんだったら
あっちもう汚い汚いと追い出すんです
毛がふわふわして可愛い
可愛い やっぱりなんでこんな猫を捨てるんですかね
私は本当にしょうがないんだから買ってあげたんだよと言って
もうカルナかぶりをするんです
欲なんですよ 何のことなく
会社で男と女がいて 男もどちらでも何かとんでもない失敗した場合は
男には怒鳴るんだけど
女には優しく始める 優しくやって
自分がちゃんとした上司として
すごいきちんと部下を管理しているんだと勘違いする
何のことないんです ただ欲だけ
欲が優しさで現れただけ
であまりたくさんあるんだから
全部もうその書いてしまったんです
アッピチタということは小欲
で 小欲をお釈迦様が推薦している素晴らしい禅なんです
時々それはいろんな被りをするんです
この小欲は で 小欲っていうのは自分の心見て小欲にならなくちゃいけないんですね
で 心という欲があるんだから
いくらあっても足らん足らないという気分でいるんです
そこで自己観察して 私にどれぐらいあれば十分なのかと考えて
自分の年もあるんだからいろいろあるでしょうに
コントロールするものっていうのは
で 欲を控えるんです 例えば六十歳になっても
もう若い女の子を見れば見るほど楽しくてたまらないと言っても
今六十歳だから まあいい加減にしろよと自分の心に言うんです
それで 異性に対する興味を抑えてもらう
食べる時でも あれも食いたい
これも食いたいじゃなくて
もういい加減なジジイだから
まあこれぐらい食っちゃえばいいんじゃないかと自分の心に言うんです
それがアッピチタの基本なんです
相手に関わりないんです
自分だけの戦いなんです
それだったら心の欲がなくなっていくんです
人格は確実に向上します
でも 世の中でいろんな人がいるんですよ
例えば いろんな人からあれこれもらうと
その分責任が生じるんです
だから責任果たすのは嫌で
いりませんと 小欲を演じちゃうんです
また 出家の世界では何もいりませんと
まあ衣と鉢と まあちょっとベッド一つだけで生活しちゃうと
信者さんも信者さんの馬鹿もいいところだから
あのお坊様が素晴らしいんだと
小欲だと いで 一生懸命お布施持っていくんです
そこで小欲を謳っているお坊さんたちのお寺なんかに行ったら
あるわあるわあるわ ものものっていうのは
何なのかと これって お釈迦様はちゃんと戒律決まってます
もし小欲実践するならば
信者さんが勝手に バカだからね
そのお坊さん狙って物持ってきたっても
まあしょうがないから受けてもいいんだけど
すぐ処分しなくちゃいけないんです
すぐないお坊さんを探してみんなに配らなくちゃいけないんです
大体坊主同士 大体はそういう生き方をしてます
だから私は皆様から何かもらうのはすごい遠慮するんですけど
相手は坊主だったらね
なんのことなくこれもらったぞと言って持っていくんです
必要なものだったら で
相手も別に何のことなくはいはいどうぞと言うんであって
私のところにあるものでも
お坊さんが来たらもう別にじゃあ勝手に持っていってというだけで
だから出家というのはそういう生活
生活するものなんです 「
いや これ私のものだから」って
自分着るもの以外はね
勝手に持っていってもいいんです
まあ勝手には持っていかないんですけど
一応あげるんです でもだいたい正欲のところに見てみると
そうではないものはいっぱい倉庫保管している
というと 結局は自分が褒めてもらうことに
まあその信者さんに認められることで喜びを感じているんです
すぐサントッティタ これは知足のことでね
あの ほんのちょっとのことで私は満足するんだぞと言って
かなりケチな人がそれをやってるんです
食べ物あるんだけど食べない
お金があるんだけど使わない
私は知足ですよと あれはただのケチだけなんです
それでケチ 物惜しみはパラヌッデータ
アッタサンラクカナタという形を取る
パラヌッデータと書いたのは
この他人のことを心配するっていう意味なんです
どういうことかというと
例えば乞食街 日本であまりないんですけど
まあインドなんかはもう恐ろしい
で あの連中は学校にも行かないで
ただ人から物を奪って
それで生活している 赤ちゃんの時からはもう物を乞うことしか教えてあげてない
で いくらあげてもいくらあげてももらう世界だからね
あ もういいっていうことはないんです
で そこであげたくない人が相手のことを真面目に心配する
こんなことをすると この子供たちは学校に行かないでしょうに
学校に行く気持ちにならないでしょうに
毎日毎日乞食に行くんだから
それでいっぱいお金もらうんだから
子供たちも考えるでしょうに
私は仕事をしなくても勉強しなくていいんじゃないか
ただこれだけでお金もらうんではないかと
そういうことは子供にとってはとんでもない悪いことだと
乞食はどんどん増えることだと
だからあげてはあかん
俺はあげませんと 結局ケチだけなんですけど
そういう風に相手のことを心配して助けてあげないんだという態度をとるんです
本人知らない自分がやっぱり助けてあげたくないだけの話なんですけど
で アッタサンラクカナタというのはもっと難しいんですが
アッタサンラクカナタは自分を守るということでね
自分を守るということにして
自分を守ることは仏教では大変ありがたい立派なことなんです
結局 自分の欲を満たすためにいろいろなことはする
まあまあ また食べ物に入りますけど
お金もあって美味しいものを食べられるんですけど
できるだけもう最低に安いものばっかり選んで食べると
そんな豪華なものを食べたらもう体に悪いんだと
だから食べませんと で
まあただケチだけ 贅沢無駄遣いしたい気持ちも欲がないという形を取る
それもあります 私は全然欲がない
だから値段いくらでもすぐ買っちゃいますと
もう高くたっても じゃあいいや
別にもうそんなにお金があったって持っていくものじゃないんだから
みんなで食べましょうと言って
で 豪華に食べたりして
これすごく贅沢に溺れてるんで
いわゆる欲に溺れてるんです
お金もばらまいたり もう誰か釈尊会の会長みたいに
かなり太っ腹を演じるんです
で これが修行でも何でもなく
ただ欲 贅沢したいだけで
本人が太っ腹で欲がなくてということを演じるんです
それで他人付き合いの人も同じことをするんです
いろんな人と仲良くしたいんです
あの人ともこの人ともあの人ともとかね
これ欲でしょうに 付き合ってる人は 4人もいるんだぞとかね
5人もいるんだぞとかね
で それはただでできるんだから
もうお金はもういくらでも使う
借金まででもして使う
欲がないわけじゃなくて逆なんです
それも自分を騙していることなんです
はい もう時間は過ぎました
まだ貪欲の辺は貪欲というか
それは性的な欲で 人に優しいと友情だと言って
まあまあ異性にすごく優しく振る舞う
結局異性に対して性的な欲がありまして
だからすごく優しい人間を演じちゃうんですね
あまりにも もう同じことで
あのー カルナ 人を助けるんだからといっても
やっぱり若い方に行く先に手が行ってしまうんです
そういうこともよくあります
はい 怒り編もありますけど
それはこれ早く終わると思いますけどね
サッと読むだけにしましょう
カンティ 忍耐っていうのは仏教で教えてる素晴らしいことなんです
それは怒りを隠すんです
で 頑固な人は他人の批判を我慢すること
例えば子供が頑固で もう絶対親言うことを聞きたくない
だから悪いことばっかりするんだから
親はさんざん怒るは怒鳴るは
じーっと我慢して聞いている
では 子供の場合は忍耐という言葉がないんだから大丈夫です
大人はそういうことをします
いろんな批判されたり
侮辱されたりするんだけど
じっと我慢している あれが怒りなんです
俺が言うことを聞いてやるもんかという態度で我慢するだけ
忍耐ではございません
忍耐っていうのは自分の心の中の問題であって
全く機能は違うんです
人格向上するものの忍耐は
時々あるでしょ もうあの人何考えてるかわからないんだと
怒鳴っても叱っても冷静にいるんだから
という風な人々いるでしょ
なんかすごい落ち着いてる
忍耐強い人のように見えちゃうんです
そうじゃないんで 結局頑固なんです
そういうアヒンサっていうのは他人に害を与えないということ
それは自分の怒りをコントロールするためと
慈悲を育てるための修行なんです
それが正義の味方になって
暴力を振るう人に暴力を振るう
苦しんでいる動物に安らぎを与えるために殺すとかね
よくあるんです だから
自分に当てるんじゃなくて
道徳が他人に当てるんです
非暴力主義はお釈迦様が何のために教えたかというと
我々はいつでも暴力主義なんです
自分に損する 損する場合はすぐ攻撃する
相手を 怒ったらすぐ相手を攻撃するという怒りという醜い汚い臭いものを持ってるんです
それで殴りたいんだけど
自分の殴りたい醜い汚い気持ちを観察して
これはあかん ブッダの真似しなくちゃいけないんだと
私はやっぱり真似するんだぞと思って自分を戒めるんですよ
だから修行は心には痛いんですよ
針を刺すんです いつでも修行するとあっちこっちから
簡単じゃないんです 非暴力主義も
結構内心はもういろんな針が刺されます
それは正しい修行で それで我慢すると怒りがなくなっちゃって非暴力主義になってしまう
ではなくて 自分の心を全く見ないで
私は非暴力主義者だ だから世の中の暴力は認めないんだぞと言って
世の中に非暴力を言いふらしちゃう
で 正義の味方になって殺したい放題人を殺す
爆弾を落とす クラスター爆弾も核兵器も何でもいいんだからっていうことで
これでももう違うんです
何言っても それでこの動物なんか苦しんでると
やっぱりかわいそうだなぁ
なんで苦しんでるのかって
もうパッと殺しちゃう
それで安らかになってくださいと
本人がいいことをしていると思っているんです
例えば 蛇がカエルを飲み込もうと思っちゃうと
蛇をぶん殴ってカエルを助けてあげる
そこでカエルさんが助けられた命拾いしましたと
よかったよかった 俺っていい人だなと
何のことないんだ あんなことです
いくらやっても自分の人格は直らないんです
熱刊また また怒りに関係ありますね
同じことです 暴力で倒産したりすると出家をする
日本でも何かとんでもない悪いことをしたら
すぐお寺に入るんです
修行して また 3ヶ月間でノコノコと社会に戻る
結婚できない年になると無欲を謳うとかね
怒ってるんです 結婚できなかったことに
その代わりに無欲を謳うとか
はい 終わった で まだたくさんあります
で 途中で申し訳ないんですけど
そのように私たちは善人だと思って自分を騙している
これ 騙しということは
本人は全く気づかないんです
例えば 時々人を助けている間で本気になって助けたくなる時もあります
その時は騙されてないんです
本当にこういうことをすることで
自分の心が穏やかになるんだっていう風になる時もあって
これぐるぐる回りますけどね
まあかなりこの騙し機能っていうのは働いていますので
良い結果は出てこないんです
以上です 以上ではありません
もう 4分の1もできなかったんで
説明するの  1冊ありますけれど
ほんの 2  3ページしか進んでないんです
では まあこれ以上はできませんので
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます